me a mom and her mother Kim and let me
just say after we sat down on a very
loud working movie set I learned
firsthand where olivia gets her sense of
humor when did you know that Olivia had
made it the truth is its when I could
buy the entire family dinner
that is my mom's bar for success like
can you we'd be at a family dinner and
I'd finally made a little bit of money
and somebody went to go um
pay one of the uncles in my mom's I
don't know she paid she paid you pay now
she pay now she's my mom is very big on
me paying for things now that I have
money
that is why I no see made it so Kim's
down with Olivia's Hollywood lifestyle
but what does she think about her
daughter's 2-year romance with NFL star
Aaron Rodgers I like him first time I
weighed in no is Olivia told me I dated
a football cornerback because I have big
families they kind of wait for them to
get married we're not even engaged
oh I'm not engaged but you thought she
was I got I saw that touch what she was
most excited I didn't know that they
know and why didn't you tell me I had
texture you believe everything on the
internet she believes everything online
if you can think of a Mother's Day that
stands out in your mind sister favorite
memories of Mother's Day either of you
growing up um my mom is not very
sentimental um when we were a kid so we
come home from school and have our
Mother's Day cards that we made for her
with instructed paper when you give it
to her and we'd sit there waiting for
her response that you look at okay thank
you and then throw it into the trash
immediately what why I have five kids
never again miss you now what about what
about Mother's Day presents well I
bought my mom a house and she wanted the
house a couple doors down from her so I
got heard that we just yeah well as for
was like mm-hmm
you got your mother house for Mother's
Day did yeah there's a house next know
how snacks two doors down for this miso
and they sold the house
and and one time when moving next to me
I asked and they get the house for me
it's the most antisocial thing you can
do is buy the house next door you
because you don't want somebody else to
buy it and move in gotta love the
honesty gonna give how hot you look I
love oh she's doing this only because
the cameras are here and that weird but
can I give my daughter a oh do you see
how she was like locating a camera
really come on give a wrong email hug he
say so look it's only really I'm ready
Ron now don't believe that for a second
cuz I saw those two off camera and they
were every bit as affectionate I adore
them